ah thank you all right how about though
I'm going to go through oh right okay
thank you hey so you from across the bar
not either buy a drink
I'm good I have one thank you good I'll
get your next one it's okay thank you
though
see how it is playing hard to get
I'm into that no I just you're not
drinking a lot tonight really cool
mm-hmm a bartender Oh what up a belated
Chad Allison pleasure to meet you yeah
what he into I'll be honest with you
Chad I'm not really into anything
between us H don't really see this going
anywhere so just want to tell you now we
made eye contact from across the bar you
gave me that look I look I think it was
just an accident you know I was looking
around the bar I just smiled you to be
friendly but it didn't really mean
anything I know my girls like you come
to the bar they want guys like me to buy
them drinks so why don't I just buy you
a drink no that's not why I came to this
bar I came to this bar because my friend
got a promotion I work and we're
celebrating and to get free drinks no
thank you
if you want me to buy you a drink why to
wear a dress like I mean it's just a
dress I like this dress a dress is
totally saying come in on me doesn't say
anything because it's a dress in the
can't talk it says I want attention it
says that girl liked that dress so she
wore that dress yeah maybe she thinks
she looks good man she's happy about
that because she spent the past six
weeks at SoulCycle working really hard
she's proud of it so that's not for you
Chad okay this for me and the dress
potty language is totally saying it on
me my body language is just beckoning
you to come talk to me I was across the
bar and I could hear what you're saying
Jed Jed take me take me me just standing
here like this means that I just want
every guy to take me okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna head out but Chad it
was interesting to meet you and have a
good night no no I'm sorry I've been
taking an unhealthy amount of acting
classes how would I describe your number
and we can start the sober at different
time a different place I have a
boyfriend oh my god I'm so I'm so sorry
is he here
can I apologize to him I mean I'm here
you could apologize to me do you have
his phone number can I call him over the
phone and just apologize it's okay you
don't need to do that you really could
tell me sooner
thanks for wasting my time
every time
[Music]